[Music]  forests absorb a huge chunk of co2  emissions MEP s are voting on a low for  the 2021 to 2030 period that would  require deforestation to be offset by  planting trees elsewhere several EU  finance ministers will discuss  revelations of the Panama papers in  their countries as well as what's being  done in response lawmakers want to boost  the use of organic fertilizers the aim  reduce the use of phosphates and  encourage waste recycling media freedom  and pluralism have come under threat in  some EU countries a public hearing will  be held to reflect on the media  landscape in Europe ideas on how to  improve search-and-rescue operations in  the Mediterranean such as better  training equipment and cooperation will  be discussed among those on the front  line